- It should be pretty easy.
Walking's easy.
We're humans.
My hearts were like, bro,
what are you doing?
(island music)
- I looked up how far
10,000 steps really is.
- Actually quite a bit.
- Almost five miles.
- Eh, 10,000 is a little daunting.
- I do a lot of life change-type things,
and I don't really commit.
And in the end I don't have any results.
Walking seems easy.
Like I can walk.
- I used to live in Chicago.
I used to walk all the time.
When I was your age,
I walked three miles to work
in the snow.
- I'm sitting at my desk.
It gets really hard to
stay active and fit.
- I don't have the best sleep schedule.
Exercise is something that
just goes out the window.
- I'm always telling me
I gotta get exercise.
I think it's time that
I get some exercise.
- I feel like my body was healthier
when I walked a lot more.
Although I did eat a
lot more frozen pizzas.
(island music)
- If I missed 10,000 steps,
I owe $10.
- I give that to charity.
- If I miss 100,000 steps,
I owe $100.
- I don't plan on giving a lot of money
to charity for this.
Maybe there will be a day
when I'm feeling generous,
and I will want to do nothing.
- Ooh. A fitbit.
- Dutu dududu dutu.
- Alright.
I love it.
- How cute.
Where do I put this on my body?
(acoustic music)
- I'm in Tennessee.
I walked so much,
I found a river.
(water flowing)
- Because it's crazy cold outside,
I am not going out there,
and I'm doing steps inside
with these guys.
- I've been sick the last few days.
It doesn't even matter
'cause I didn't have my fitbit
in my pocket for the last five days.
- I am walking at work.
I decided to walk to lunch today.
Look at that, we're gonna walk.
We're gonna get a lot of steps in.
- [Voiceover] Help me, come on guys.
- Okay.
- Let's go.
(acoustic music)
- Whoo!
I am shocked by that
but I'll take it.
- I'm in second place.
Me?
- Heah.
I'm at the bottom,
but I still have the
chance to turn it around.
I have good excuses why I haven't
hit those marks.
It's 40 degrees outside and raining,
and it's been that way all day.
- And you realize you've only done half
the amount of steps you're supposed to do.
And your bed is so warm.
- Umm. I don't know if
that's gonna happen.
- It's really hard to go do it.
- Having the dog is a great excuse
'cause he gets me up
right away in the morning.
- It forces me to walk.
It really does.
On weekends, I'm just laying in my bed,
and it's like,
I could just be walking.
I am walking in my neighborhood.
I feel better.
It would make me feel
like I'm actually doing something.
(acoustic music)
- So guys, who isn't here right now?
- Umm.
- Jen.
Isn't here.
- Sleeping.
- She's at home right now.
- What a piece of shit.
- (laughing)
(acoustic music)
- No. Why?
- (laughing)
- C'mon.
(very hard breathing)
- Each step is so hard.
My legs aren't like you
in jeans Keith.
My hearts were like bro,
what are you doing?
(acoustic music)
(wind blowing)
- You know who didn't make it?
Jen.
- Jen tiger.
(acoustic music)
- I want to blame the influenza virus.
There was a day that
I did wear the fitbit,
and I walked 100 steps.
(laughing)
- Being the biggest loser also means
that I'm the biggest philanthropist.
I'm gonna give it to Alzheimer's.
That's a good charity to give money to.
- Well no, I just was last before
so I was kind of anticipating being last.
I did a lot better when
I was back at work.
Emailing made me get up and walk.
I think I'm gonna donate my money
to a high school that's in Watts
for the neighborhood boys.
- Look at that.
I was in Chicago for a
like a week and a half.
And it was freezing.
And that entire week is just a wash.
I owe $47.
I think I'll give it to Saint Jude,
the children's hospital.
- That's a safe bet.
- [Voiceover] You owe a dollar.
- That was so close.
- You must have done 10,000
almost every day.
- I tried.
- That's amazing.
- That's the difference.
If you try,
- (laughing)
you'll almost make it.
- So who you're giving nine bucks to?
- I feel like giving them $9 is a joke.
- Maybe you just throw $9
on one of our charities.
- I think I'm gonna go
with sick little kids.
- Again,
that's the safe bet.
(all laughing)
- I like feel like I probably will.
It's slightly obsessive to
like constantly
- Yes.
- know what number it is.
Like a little game
you're playing every day.
- I think the only thing
that I did slightly more
with this is like always take the stairs
when I was at work.
Doing a little bit of extra effort.
You know, the bare minimum extra.
- (laughing)
- I'm doing that.
- I'm definitely not gonna feel bad
if I don't hit 10,000 any more.
I'm not gonna stress about it.
But I'll at least try.
- Alright, we did it!
- [Voiceover] Whoo, whoo!
(hands clapping)
- [Voiceover] My life has changed.
(squeaking sign)